(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Tem aqui um edital de um leilão judicial
realizado pela 22ª Vala Cível do Foro Central
de São Paulo.
Aqui tem os dados do edital, o nome
do executado, o nome do exequente, o nome
do juiz e outras informações, data do leilão
e tal.
Vamos seguir aqui para o que importa para
a gente, que a gente quer analisar nessa
aula, que é débitos.
Dois débitos.
Eventuais ondas sobre imóvel ocorrerão por conta do
arrematante, exceto débitos de IPTU e demais taxas
e impostos que serão subrogados no valor da
arrematação, nos termos do artigo 130, capto de
parágrafo único do CTN.
Então aqui é o exemplo mais clássico do
que a gente encontra, o Estal só falando
ali dos débitos de IPTU, deixando em aberto
para o débito de condomínio, então a gente
precisa analisar de fato o concurso de credores.
Esse leilão aqui, ele não é um leilão
de dívida de cobrança de condomínio.
Quem está cobrando essa dívida é esse espólio
de Maria.
Isso aqui era uma dívida de cobrança de
uma fiança, um fiador não pagou a dívida
que ele garantiu e aí ele está tendo
um imóvel levado a leilão.
Então já que a gente precisa analisar o
concurso de credores, partir aqui para a matrícula
desse imóvel.
Então a gente tem aqui a matrícula do
imóvel, o cartório que está registrado, o número
da matrícula, os dados do apartamento, só fazer
uma análise geral aqui.
Tem o número do apartamento, na própria matrícula
tem duas vagas de garagem, sempre faça isso
para você não arrematar o imóvel sem vaga.
Tinha lá anteriormente a propriedade da gafisa imobiliária,
a gafisa deu uma hipoteca ao banco Citibank,
essa hipoteca ficou cancelada na verbação 2, ou
seja, não existe mais a hipoteca.
Registro 3, gafisa vendeu para Marcos Vinícius Lobregat,
então está aqui em 98.
Registro 4, o Marcos deu em hipoteca o
imóvel para garantia da dívida.
A verbação 5, pelo instrumento referido no registro
3, que é a compra pelo Marcos, a
credora cedeu seus direitos creditórios decorrentes do registro
4, que é a hipoteca, ao banco Citibank,
ou seja, o Marcos comprou o imóvel no
registro 4, ele fez a hipoteca, e aqui
na verbação 5, essa hipoteca passou a ser
do Citibank.
A verbação 6, cancelou a hipoteca do registro
4, ou seja, a hipoteca não existe mais.
Então, até agora, nada de ônus nessa hipoteca,
e o imóvel é do Marcos.
A verbação 7, ajuizamento de execução.
Não é uma vara trabalhista, porque está aqui,
vara cível, se fosse vara trabalhista, estaria vara
trabalhista, ou seja, não é um processo trabalhista,
não é um credor trabalhista.
Então está aqui, pelo cartório da 11ª vara
cível, do Foro Central Cível, nos autos da
execução de título extrajudicial, procede-se à verbação,
para constar que foi ajuizada a ação de
execução, movida pelo Bradesco, em face de Lobregate
Advogados e Marcos Vinícius, que é de fato
o proprietário desse imóvel.
A verbação número 8, penhora.
Penhora da 22ª vara cível do Foro Central
da Comarca da Capital, nos autos da execução
civil, movida por Armen e Ega, contra Lobregate
e Marcos Vinícius, foi penhorado o imóvel para
garantir uma dívida de R$ 190 mil.
Essa penhora aqui é a penhora que está
levando o imóvel a leilão, porque essa Armen,
no momento em que ela entrou com o
processo, ela era viva, e depois ela morreu
no curso do processo.
Então, por isso que agora está lá o
espólio.
O espólio é quem representa os bens de
uma pessoa que morreu.
Então, a verbação número 8, outra penhora.
A verbação número 9, cancelamento de ajuizamento de
execução.
Fica cancelada a verbação de ajuizamento de execução,
objeto da verbação 7, em virtude da autorização
dada pelo exequente Banco Bradesco.
Então, vamos lá.
Tinha aqui essa execução, e essa execução não
existe mais.
Ou seja, provavelmente o Marcos fez um acordo,
pagou lá o que ele estava devendo, ou
aquela dívida que estava sendo cobrada, o juiz
reconheceu que não deve ser paga por algum
motivo.
Não importa pra gente, o que importa é
que não existe mais essa execução.
Então, o que a gente tem até agora
de ônus nesse imóvel é essa penhora 8
aqui, que inclusive é a que está levando
o imóvel a leilão.
Continuando, penhora 10.
Penhora feita por ordem da Vara de Trabalho
de São Paulo.
Então, só de você ler, você já sabe
se é uma penhora trabalhista, de um credor
trabalhista ou não.
Se for vara cível, não é credor trabalhista.
Se for vara do trabalho, é credor trabalhista.
Então, aqui o Marcos tem um credor trabalhista,
que é a Renata, que ela penhorou o
imóvel pra cobrar uma dívida de 16 mil
reais, na época que essa dívida foi penhorada,
em 2018.
Então, pode ser que essa dívida seja realmente
muito maior que esses 16 mil reais.
E, por fim, penhora número 11.
Movida pelo condomínio.
Então, é um processo numa vara cível, movida
pelo condomínio, cobrando valores de condomínio em atraso
do Marcos Vinicius.
O imóvel foi penhorado naquele momento pra cobrar
uma dívida de 45 mil reais.
Provavelmente, essa dívida também é muito maior, já
que essa penhora foi em fevereiro de 2019.
Todos os valores que não estavam sendo pagos
têm juros sendo aplicados e também, mês a
mês, tem novos valores.
Então, vamos lá.
O que o Edital falou?
O Edital só falou aqui, deixa eu achar,
dois débitos.
Ele só fala do débito de IPTU, ele
não fala nada do débito de condomínio.
Por isso que a gente tem que analisar
o concurso de credores, porque não seria justo
o Marcos pagar somente a penhora que está
levando o imóvel a leilão e deixar as
outras penhoras lá sem serem pagas e o
juiz liberar o dinheiro na mão dele.
Então, tem essa penhora que está levando o
imóvel a leilão, é a penhora 8, existe
a penhora trabalhista, 10, e existe a penhora
do condomínio, 11.
Pra isso que existe o concurso de credores.
Como é a ordem do concurso de credores?
Em primeiro lugar, crédito alimentício, credores trabalhistas e
pensão alimentícia.
Em segundo lugar, débitos tributários.
Em terceiro lugar, créditos com garantia real.
Em quarto lugar, as penhoras de acordo com
a ordem cronológica da penhora.
Essa numeração de averbação das penhoras.
Então, vamos começar aqui.
Quem está levando o imóvel a leilão é
a verbação 8.
E na verbação 10, que vem depois da
8, tem uma penhora trabalhista.
Não importa que essa penhora trabalhista venha depois
da penhora que está levando o imóvel a
leilão.
Ela vai receber em primeiro lugar, porque ela
é um credor preferencial.
Então, quem recebe em primeiro lugar aqui nesse
caso?
Renata.
A Renata vai receber em primeiro lugar, apesar
da averbação de penhora dela ser depois da
averbação que está levando, de fato, o imóvel
a leilão.
A Renata vai passar na frente de todo
mundo.
Não interessa, porque ela é uma credora trabalhista.
Ela tem preferência.
O que você precisaria fazer nesse caso também?
Recorrer aos links que estão aqui nessa aula
para saber se o Marcos, se ele tem
mais processos trabalhistas que estão ali cobrando a
ele, para saber se algum processo trabalhista já
está na fase final ali de execução, se
já tem o valor certo, para que você
considere isso no seu concurso de credores, já
que se tiver e só aparecer depois da
sua análise, esse credor trabalhista que possa existir
também vai passar na frente.
Nesse caso aqui, de fato, o Marcos não
tinha, só tinha a Renata mesmo.
Então, em primeiro lugar, vai pagar a Renata.
E depois, vamos ver como é que continua.
Como não é uma dívida de condomínio, e
o condomínio é a última penhora aqui da
matrícula, penhora 11, quem vai receber em segundo
lugar vai ser essa penhora aqui da ARNEM.
Mas vamos continuar analisando o concurso na ordem
certinha para vocês entenderem.
Crédito trabalhista, tem.
Tem crédito trabalhista, tem a Renata.
Apesar da averbação dela não ser a primeira
matrícula, ela vai passar na frente porque ela
é uma credora preferencial.
Segundo lugar, créditos tributários.
Crédito tributário aqui, nesse caso, seria o IPTU.
E aqui, uma atenção.
Dificilmente você vai achar a averbação de uma
penhora de cobrança de IPTU na matrícula de
imóvel.
Nenhum problema, porque o entendimento do STJ também
é de que não precisa dessa averbação de
penhora para que o município cobre as dívidas
tributárias que ele tem direito a receber.
Então, a IPTU vai entrar de qualquer jeito
aqui nessa dívida, nesse montante da arrematação.
Então, primeiro lugar aqui, nesse caso, Renata.
Segundo lugar, IPTU.
Esse imóvel aqui, ele está em dívida de
IPTU.
Terceiro lugar, crédito com garantia real.
Hipoteca ou alienação fiduciária.
Esse imóvel aqui nunca teve alienação fiduciária.
E esse imóvel aqui já teve hipoteca, mas
a hipoteca não existe mais porque a gente
viu que a hipoteca foi cancelada na matrícula
do imóvel.
Quarto lugar, aí sim, os credores na ordem
cronológica das penhoras.
Então, passando aqui, ordem cronológica das penhoras.
A Armen vai receber antes do condomínio porque
ela está na verbação 8 e o condomínio
está na verbação 11.
Então, nesse caso concreto aqui, ficará da seguinte
forma.
Renata, prefeitura com IPTU, Armen e condomínio.
O que você precisa saber?
O montante dessa dívida para você saber se
o valor da arrematação vai ser suficiente para
pagar ou não.
Se for suficiente para pagar, arremata tranquilamente sem
nenhuma dor de cabeça.
Então, os valores na época atualizados eram os
seguintes.
Renata, apesar de estar aqui com R$16
mil, o crédito dela estava em R$40
mil.
O IPTU está em um montante de dívida
de R$80 mil.
Então, R$40 com R$80, R$120.
Essa penhora da Armen, ela atualizada, estava em
R$220 mil.
Então, R$120 mil mais R$220 mil.
R$340 mil.
E o condomínio atualizado estava em R$70
mil.
Então, R$340 mais R$70 mil.
R$410 mil.
O valor mínimo da arrematação em segunda praça
desse leilão aqui, já com desconto concedido pelo
juiz, era de R$501 mil.
Ou seja, mais do que suficiente para pagar
todas essas dívidas e ainda sobra ali um
valor que vai ser liberado na mão do
devedor depois que todas essas dívidas forem pagas,
que aí sim, de fato, é justo liberar
a diferença na mão do devedor, porque ele
quitou tudo que ele estava devendo e ele
tem direito a esse saldo.
Então, essa análise que você sempre precisa fazer,
porque não necessariamente o EGITAL deixar lá o
condomínio de fora, significa direto que o condomínio
vai ser de responsabilidade do arrematante.
Aqui, nesse caso, um condomínio de R$70
mil, completamente pago com o valor da arrematação,
não sobraria nada para o arrematante.
Vamos aqui para um segundo exemplo.
Então, tenho aqui mais um EGITAL de leilão
judicial, Terceira Vara Cível, do Foro Regional de
Penha de França, comarca de São Paulo.
Nome dos executados e é uma ação de
cobrança de despesas condominiais.
Cumprimento de sentença, está aqui o número do
processo e o nome do condomínio que está
cobrando esse valor, do Paulo e da Vanderlita.
Então, aqui um sinal de alerta, porque é
uma dívida cobrada por um condomínio e isso
aí pode mudá-la ao nosso concurso de
credores, exatamente pela súmula do STJ, que diz
que o crédito condominial passa na frente do
crédito hipotecário, se for por um processo movido
pelo condomínio.
E esse aqui é o condomínio residencial.
E o número do processo.
Então, vamos lá.
Nome da juíza, todos os nomes do leiloeiro,
número de inscrição do leiloeiro na junta comercial
aqui de São Paulo, os dados do apartamento,
e aqui ele diz, ó, débitos de IPTU,
nada consta, você vai conferir mesmo se realmente
não tem nenhum débito.
Está aqui o número do contribuinte, também você
acharia ali na matrícula do imóvel.
Diz os horários, o valor mínimo de segunda
e primeira praça, o valor mínimo de primeira
e segunda praça, possibilidade de parcelamento, possibilidade de
remissão, que é se o executado ou qualquer
interessado, após a publicação digital, quitar a dívida,
esse valor de 2% deve ser pago
pelo executado pro leiloeiro, porque, afinal de contas,
o leiloeiro trabalhou, chegou até ali porque ele
não estava pagando a dívida, o executado não
estava pagando a dívida, o leiloeiro trabalhou.
Se o executado tirar de última hora o
imóvel ali de leilão, ele tem que pagar
esse valorzinho que ficou estipulado no edital pro
leiloeiro.
E aqui está o que interessa pra gente.
Débitos tributários e demais débitos.
Então vamos ler.
Débitos tributários.
Eventuais débitos tributários ficam subrogados no valor da
arrematação nos termos do artigo 130 do Código
Tributário Nacional.
Demais débitos.
Eventuais outros débitos que recaiam sobre o imóvel
são de responsabilidade do arrematante, inclusive os débitos
de condomínio não cobertos pelo valor da arrematação.
Cabe ao interessado pesquisar diretamente junto ao condomínio,
as entidades e órgãos competentes a existência e
o valor de eventuais débitos e ônus sobre
o bem leiloado.
Então subrogou ali o IPTU, mas falou que
o condomínio, se não for pago integralmente com
o valor da arrematação, sobraria, de fato, pro
arrematante.
Então a gente precisa analisar novamente se o
valor da arrematação vai ser suficiente pra quitar
a IPTU e o condomínio e se o
arrematante vai receber esse bem livre de ônus.
Vou descer aqui que a gente tem a
matrícula do imóvel.
Então está aqui.
Décimo do segundo ofício, o número da matrícula,
os dados do imóvel.
Era primeiro proprietário, né?
Pró-morar e engenharia.
Registro número 1.
Por instrumento particular, os proprietários, que era pró
-morar, venderam para Paulo e sua mulher, Vanderlita,
que são os executados da ação.
São, de fato, os proprietários do imóvel.
Então está aqui no registro 1.
Registro 2.
Paulo e Vanderlita hipotecaram o imóvel dessa matrícula
para o Banco Bradesco.
Averbação 3.
Juiz da vara cível determinou que nenhum registro
seja efetuado nessa matrícula.
Então proibiu ali que o Paulo vendesse o
imóvel, alguma coisa do tipo.
Realmente proibiu que algum registro fosse realizado nessa
matrícula.
Averbação número 3 está aqui.
Averbação número 4.
Por mandado da sexta vara cível, é feita
essa averbação para constar que fica cancelada a
averbação número 3 feita nessa matrícula.
Ou seja, a juíza proibiu que qualquer registro
fosse feito na matrícula na averbação número 3,
começa aqui, termina aqui.
E na averbação número 4, essa mesma juíza
da sexta vara cível determinou que cancelasse essa
proibição.
Ou seja, pode efetuar registro na matrícula, não
tem mais essa proibição porque a averbação número
4 cancelou a averbação número 3.
Averbação número 5.
Penhora online do terceiro ofício cível do Foro
Regional.
Terceiro ofício cível é sinônimo de terceira vara
cível.
Para apenhorar a quantia de R$ 37
mil, na época, por uma dívida cobrada pelo
residencial Viladeixe em face de Paulo e Vanderlita.
Ou seja, o condomínio cobrando a dívida do
Paulo e da Vanderlita porque eles deixaram de
pagar.
E aí acaba, não tem mais nada aqui
nessa matrícula.
Então, conforme o edital falou para a gente,
crédito tributário subrogado, crédito condomínio, será pago com
o valor da arrematação se for suficiente.
Se não for suficiente, a diferença será de
responsabilidade do arrematante.
Você precisa ver se o valor da arrematação
é suficiente para pagar IPTU mais condomínio.
Então, essa aqui é uma dívida cobrada num
processo de condomínio.
Está aqui.
Ação de cobrança de despesa condominal requerida pelo
condomínio.
E aqui está o número do processo.
Então, ordem do concurso de credores, geralmente, crédito
trabalhista e pensão alimentícia, crédito tributário, crédito com
garantia real, hipoteca e aliança fiduciária e demais
penhoras de acordo com a ordem cronológica das
averbações.
Crédito trabalhista.
Você abriu lá o link aqui do TRT
de São Paulo, que está anexo nessa aula,
e viu que o Paulo e a Vanderlita
não têm processo trabalhista em curso.
Pulou o ponto 1, não tem ninguém para
cobrar lá, ninguém para passar na frente.
Crédito 2, crédito tributário.
E aqui nesse caso, não tem nenhuma penhora
ali da União, do Estado, cobrando algo do
Paulo e da Vanderlita.
E você precisaria ficar atento no débito de
IPTU, que realmente não vai existir a penhora,
mesmo se não existir, vai ser pago ali
na frente, porque o STJ diz assim.
E você precisaria ver se tem débito de
IPTU.
O próprio edital aqui informa que não tem
débito de IPTU.
Você só realmente reforçaria essa busca.
Terceiro lugar, crédito com garantia real.
Lá é exemplo da hipoteca.
Atenção aqui nesse caso, é um processo movido
pelo condomínio.
O que a exceção lá da súmula do
STJ diz?
Em processo movido por condomínio, o condomínio passa
na frente da hipoteca.
Então você precisaria analisar realmente se isso aí
seria suficiente para pagar condomínio IPTU.
E depois, como é um processo movido pelo
condomínio, seria a hipoteca o quarto lugar.
Esse imóvel aqui, ele tem hipoteca.
Está aqui.
Registro número 2, hipoteca com o Bradesco.
E depois não existe registro cancelando.
Não tem nada cancelando a hipoteca.
Ou seja, a hipoteca está valendo.
Mas não importa, porque é processo de condomínio,
e o condomínio vai passar na frente da
hipoteca, vai receber antes.
Então se o valor da arrematação for suficiente
para pagar IPTU e condomínio, tudo livre para
o arrematante, e essa hipoteca vai cair, o
Bradesco, que é o criador hipotecário, deixa eu
só conferir aqui.
Sim, é o Bradesco.
Ele vai ter que procurar outros bens do
Paulo e da Vanderlita para cobrar essa hipoteca,
porque essa é uma característica da hipoteca.
Se você não lembra bem, volte lá na
aula de hipoteca, aqui no módulo 3.
Então a hipoteca é diferente de relação fiduciária.
Só faça sempre essa distinção.
A hipoteca, se o criador hipotecário for intimado,
ela cai, não é de responsabilidade do arrematante,
o arrematante não vai pagar aquilo.
E a relação fiduciária é diferente, que a
relação fiduciária, quando existe um imóvel que está
em um leilão judicial, ela vai gerar um
leilão de direitos.
E aí, nesse caso, sim, alerta é ligado,
porque pode sobrar o financiamento para o arrematante.
Na hipoteca, não, então.
Então o que você precisaria ver, nesse caso,
é se o valor da arrematação seria suficiente
para quitar IPTU e condomínio.
Traduzindo em valores, o valor da arrematação mínima
aqui da 2ª Praça, já com desconto aplicado
pelo juiz, um pouco mais de 159 mil
reais.
IPTU realmente zerado, esse imóvel é isento de
IPTU pela Prefeitura, então não tem nada a
pagar para a Prefeitura.
E condomínio, o valor da dívida estava somando
um pouco mais de 120 mil reais.
Ou seja, 120 mil é menor do que
159 mil, que é o valor mínimo da
arrematação.
Se alguém arrematar pelo valor mínimo, vai ficar
livre de condomínio e IPTU.
Essa diferençazinha aí que sobraria, né, iria para
o Bradesco.
E se não for suficiente para pagar o
Bradesco, o problema é do Bradesco, nada em
relação ao arrematante, já que é uma hipoteca,
o Bradesco que busca outros imóveis do arrematante
para pagar aquela dívida.
Então, a análise que você precisa fazer é
sempre essa.
Você vai lá ver o que o gestor
está falando, vai ver se é necessário analisar
o concurso de credores, se for necessário, analise,
né, é algo que aí com a prática
vai ser algo simples para você analisar, vai
te passar confiança, e aí sim você sabe
se o imóvel vai vir livre de dívidas
para você ou se você precisa considerar alguma
dívida ali na sua viabilidade financeira.